the l.a county department of health is
responding after seth rogen called out
the primetime emmy awards for not
abiding by covet health and safety
protocols
yeah so for those who didn't see it seth
took to the stage to announce the first
award of the night at sunday's show and
delivered a list of jokes before calling
out the show which was held in a tented
bathroom outdoors in l.a
let me start by saying there is way too
many of us in this little room
what are we doing
they said this was outdoors
it's not
they lied to us
we're in a hermetically sealed tent
right now
i would not have come to this
why is there a roof i went from wiping
my groceries to having paul bettany
sneeze in my face so
that's a big week
all right emmy's dj reggie watts did
clarify that after everyone at the show
had been fully vaccinated and the l.a
county department of health confirmed to
tmz that no rules were broken and that
the emmys were quote exceeded the
baseline requirements for television and
film
productions yeah okay so this is
actually news to me so since the award
show qualified as a tv production and
those attending were considered
performers no one actually had to wear
masks all attendees also had to test
negative within 48 hours of the show in
addition to being fully vaxxed i
actually didn't really realize that so
in a sense
i don't think anything really bad
happened there do you no i think that
the optics are bad that's what i think i
think that it looks like i think that it
looks like rules for certain people and
rules and rules for everybody else this
was clearly not the intent behind a tv
and film production
no you know tv rarely do you ever see a
tv and film production that would have
that many extras in one room they
started this with the oscars last year
when soderberg came in uh and executive
produced those where they originally the
way even the way that he described it
was going to be a series of vignettes
and they were going to do a lot of
over-the-shoulder shots to sort of trick
people into thinking or trick the
authorities into thinking that this was
more of a television production than it
was a giant banquet which is all this
really is um and i don't know these seem
these rules seem kind of like you know
certain things that they have to follow
and then certain things that other
people may the rules may not have been
broken but the ops the optics are
atrocious
yeah okay so what's what do you think
then do you just not have award shows
yet no i think they do they're going to
keep pushing this i don't i mean i know
seth rogen is funny as hell right and
and i yeah but there's no doubt in my
mind that he legitimately went there
that night thinking that they were going
to be outside
and i think that that's part of it right
is yes it's outside they built a tent
but it's outside that's not outside and
any rational person would understand
that um what do you do i don't know it's
i i wouldn't go right i wouldn't go but
can you see this kind of stuff no you
can't i mean you know as many people
were you know three times four times the
amount of people that were watching the
emmys were watching a football game on
another channel and there was more
people in that stadium than there was
sitting at the emmys so what are you
gonna do i wouldn't go but
yeah
yeah i hear what you're saying paul is
saying so true good on seth would really
make me nervous regardless being so
close to so many people right now i
agree